you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news live from cop 26 in glasgow
where a reality check has been delivered
to those trying to keep 1.5 alive
scientists warn that even with all the
target pledges made at the summit the
world is still headed for well over two
degrees of warming
the focus here today has been on
progressing gender equality with women
and girls making up 80 percent of those
displaced by climate change
and i'm live in the brazilian city of
rio de janeiro we'll hear from one man
creating an urban mangrove forest to
help fight climate change and the
president he says does not care
in neighboring peru we report from the
melting glaciers which could endanger
the water supply of one of the driest
capitals on earth while in india chennai
is hit by flooding caused by
unseasonable rain
back here in scotland we'll see how
locally farmed seaweed is doing its bit
to help mitigate the effects of climate
change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show live from cop 26 in glasgow where
the summit's president alok sharma has
said progress is being made but admitted
there's still a mountain to climb to
help give negotiators the final push
boris johnson has said this evening that
he'll come back here tomorrow and this
time by train well his return comes
after a bleak message from the
scientists who've scrutinized what's
been agreed so far
analysis from the climate action tracker
has today suggested that existing
pledges will reduce global warming by
just a few tenths of a degree raising
serious concerns over the effort to keep
1.5 alive
without further long-term pledges global
temperatures are instead forecasted to
rise by 2.4 degrees by 2100 as our
science editor tom clark reports
chennai is underwater again for the
second time in six years
the intensity and frequency of monsoons
is part of our changing climate
as india faces its impacts thousands of
miles away the world is running out of
time to stop it if you look at the
consequences of going higher in terms of
what's going to happen to countries
around the world extreme weather events
sea rising you know island
nations that are really
in trouble some of them now
so 1.5 has to be the target
is it achievable yes but it's tough but
action so far hasn't been enough we now
have the first analysis of how much of a
difference last week's major
announcements at cop 26 will make
pledges from phasing out coal to cutting
methane and saving forests
the whole purpose of this summit is to
limit global warming to one and a half
degrees centigrade by the end of the
century but because we might get to that
point as early as the 2030s this
analysis looked at 20 30 pledges
combined they take us well beyond one
and a half degrees of warming to 2.4
degrees by the end of the century
and even in a really optimistic scenario
which includes very shaky pledges like
ending deforestation we still get to 1.8
degrees of warming by 2100
on one level it's great progress we were
facing three degrees of warming earlier
this year but it's shattering cop 26
president alok sharma's bid to keep 1.5
alive can you tell us in concrete terms
what has to happen in the next few days
to make sure this isn't the summit where
1.5 dies
we are of course very clearly focused on
ensuring that we are keeping 1.5 within
reach where we get to is going to emerge
through consensus uh you know we'll have
the cover decision going out overnight
and i'm sure there'll be questions on
that as well during the press conference
tomorrow
the cover decision is the negotiating
document that marks the beginning of the
end game here
outside the demonstrations continued
live to the reality there are now just
three days left to agree the plan to
save the planet
they chose an obvious but entirely
accurate metaphor
if these talks fail we all go down
together whether you're in china chennai
or the chile clyde tom clark sky news
glasgow
so tomorrow we'll see the return of
boris johnson but so far this week has
seen the return of the americans after
four years of the trump administration
the democrats are keen to make their
presence felt with barack obama in town
yesterday and today our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter caught
up with the house speaker nancy pelosi
how much does american leadership matter
on this issue right now
well enormously i because our leader of
the world when and we had made a big
commitment uh to change
and uh we're back in it's unfortunate
that the last four years before previous
four years
i've ever done
i've done a lot of bad ones and hannah's
here with me now so hannah show a force
then from the americans this week but
how much difference can they make well
there is something about the american
use of soft power and it's back and
forth as you say this time around uh
lots of administration representatives
have spoken uh of this kind of lingering
shame of the donald trump era who of
course pulled america out of the paris
climate court and there are some other
domestic problems as well though even
though we've now moved on from donald
trump joe biden has had to preside over
a real wrangling in congress to get
through some crucial climate change
legislation and some of it still hasn't
passed so there's a real awareness i
think amongst the american contingent
that they've staked an awful lot on the
success of this big summit while also
they're dealing with problems at home i
caught up with one of the big stars of
the american climate change movement
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
and i asked her about whether or not in
the post-trump era the u.s has actually
made a full recovery of its moral
authority and this is what she had to
say
no
we have not
uh recovered our moral authority
i believe that we are making steps
but
also kind of in reference to the earlier
question
we have to actually deliver the action
in order to get the respect and
authority internationally to get the
credit uh we have to draw down emissions
to get credit for being committed on
climate change it's really that simple
a really blunt assessment there and an
awful lot riding on getting that
domestic agenda done
but
they know that their focus has to be
marshaling nations together at cop 26 to
get all these complicated disagreements
ironed out and i think that is their
focus right now despite the problems at
home and that is why boris johnson is
coming back to glasgow tomorrow
to see if he can frankly crack some
heads together and get this done hannah
thank you
and good evening from rio de janeiro in
brazil a country of course so crucial in
the fight
against uh climate change more from here
in just a moment but first in
neighboring peru sky news has been told
that the country is on the edge of
disaster with a deepening water crisis
for which there is no
plan about 72 percent of the world's
tropical glaciers are located in peru
they're among the world's fastest
retreating mountain ice caps but
scientists fear that many of the
country's largest glaciers will have all
but disappeared by the mid-2050s
lima also known as the desert capital is
one of the driest capital cities in the
world without the water from glaciers
the city and the surrounding communities
could face severe water scarcity well
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
hiked up to the edge of peru's receding
janapacha glacier in cordillera blanca
mountain range and he sent this report
is high in the peruvian andes
these mountains are home to huge
glaciers that provide water for farming
and drinking to millions across northern
peru but they're literally melting away
at an astonishing rate one third have
gone in just ten years
seventy two percent of the world's
tropical glaciers are here
they exist around the equator at
altitudes above 4000 meters but because
of their position on the equator they
are particularly sensitive to climate
change
as the world warms the glaciers retreat
you used to be able to drive to the
places in peru to see them now you have
to walk
charlie good has been here for 17 years
he took us to the janapacha glacier at
just under 5000 meters
the changes to the mountains and its
glaciers because of global warming are
he says all too obvious to see
you can see that massive rock slab which
is now exposed when i was here 17 years
ago or maybe even 15 years ago
that has receded all the way way back so
a couple of hundred meters
um and when i was actually up here in
november a couple of years ago we had
about no there's maybe one waterfall
coming off a glacier in november when
the sun's almost directly overhead
because we're tropical there were nine
waterfalls coming off there that means
it's not very british i mean it's it's
just it's melting before your eyes i
mean i was crying i was filming a clip
and just crying about how much water is
coming off that glacier
the melting waters from the glaciers
fill huge lakes that in turn provide
water further downstream
too much water and they flood and the
water is lost
climate change and increasing
temperatures hit this part of the world
in the 1970s glaciers started melting
that wasn't a disaster because huge
amounts of water was released went down
the valleys and went eventually all the
way to the deserts near the coast where
there was a farming bonanza because of
the huge amount of water that was
created
the problem is that water and
agriculture was dependent upon these
glaciers but they are melting at an
incredible rate
very soon perhaps in the next two
decades there won't be any water and
those farms will all be in desert once
again
across northern peru the glacial waters
are directed into vast farms it's
produce exported worldwide
these are strawberries grown on the side
of the mountain
[Music]
experts say that increasingly erratic
climate conditions and the drop in
glacier water is threatening these farms
existence the water that comes
one of the world's leading authorities
on this is cesar porter guerrero he's
been warning peru and the world about
the effects of climate change for two
decades
now he says we're on the edge of
disaster
we have to think in the new generation
not in us
we are going to live this nice world in
some time
in the near future but we are leaving
the problem as james hansen say storms
for our grandchildren we are leaving the
problem for them
and if we love them we should work
things now
lima is one of the world's driest
capitals it barely rains
without the precious glacial water that
is directed to the centre of town it
would all look like this
a desert with people struggling to live
even the people on the edge of town
depend on water channeled to them from
the glaciers
without the glaciers there is no life
stew ramsey sky news peru
well rio de janeiro where i am now is
considered one of the more vulnerable
cities in latin america when it comes to
climate change vulnerable to rising
temperatures rising sea levels and
particularly to landslides destroying
the shanty towns or favelas dotted on
the hillsides around this city
but one biologist here who considers
president bolsonaro's policies a
disaster for the planet is a one-man
mission to confront global warming
in a swamp on the edge of rio stands a
biologist consumed by the fight against
climate change and against a president
he says doesn't care
we have a strange president when the
issue is the environment
we're walking through mario moscatelli's
passion project this ecosystem is very
important he is working to create the
biggest urban mangrove forest in brazil
this is one way to uh fight
against uh the the climate change it's
very very very important these trees
this is a settling of the seedling yeah
yes
he's planted three quarters of a square
mile so far and is keeping going
this is a new planting
but it is not straightforward the
disastrous habits of man are taking
their toll here
we have tires
television
domestic garbage
an unending tide of debris is just about
kept at bay by an unstable fence
but it is unremitting
and it is depressing
so this is
your nightmare yeah you're trying to
build
you're trying to build a new this is my
dream and here is nightmare
yes
mario says it all means too much of
their time here is spent doing this
rather than planting trees the cleanup
is never ending
what we're witnessing here is quite
incredible one man and his team battling
against pollution battling against uh
climate change but you can see just what
they're up against here
further in we walk towards what his
dream is all about be careful please
this is of course tiny stuff when
confronted with vast areas of rainforest
being destroyed as i speak
but these seedlings were planted last
year and many many more are planned by a
man so desperate to change things here
at least some hope is taking root right
now
in mario's mangrove
and there's much more from here in
brazil in the next hour but now back to
anna in the studio
mark thank you well here in scotland an
unusual natural product is increasingly
being used to help fight climate change
in the search for clean energy seaweed
is now powering cars as well as making
packaging our science correspondent
thomas moore reports
the clean cold waters of scotland's west
coast perfect conditions for seaweed and
peter elborn is growing it on ropes
below the surface
get to january the light comes back and
nutrients and the water come back
everything is there ready for these
series to start growing really fast
centimeters a day
by may when the seaweed is harvested to
use in food products it'll be two meters
tall and that growth helps mitigate
climate change our seaweed grows it's
absorbing oceanic carbon this year we
would expect it to be
a relatively modest scale rat at the
moment so perhaps around a half a tonne
of carbon dioxide equivalent that we're
absorbing from the ocean
by some estimates seaweed soaks up five
times as much carbon as the same area of
forest assessments of wild kelp suggest
it absorbs more than 200 million tons of
carbon globally when we talk about
capturing carbon we often think about
planting trees but trees take space on
land land that has a myriad of other
uses out here there's no such
competition the seaweed here provides a
habitat for fish and it cleans up the
water it is a win-win for the
environment
but the environmental benefits are a
happy coincidence the driver for farming
is seaweed's growing range of uses in
its open lab oceanium can extract
protein fiber and minerals it's making a
compostable bioplastic for packaging and
in future seaweed could even replace oil
as a source of building blocks for the
chemical industry you've got very cold
habitats very hot habitats you've you've
got some quite extreme environments and
seaweed is occupies all of those niches
so it solved a lot of
chemical and physical problems to
survive and that creates a diversity of
chemistry and products that we can use
and develop into things that solve our
problems
seaweed farming doesn't let us off
making huge reductions to greenhouse gas
emissions but the carbon it captures
could help the world reach net zero
thomas more sky news in urban
well let's talk now about what's been
going on today in glasgow with judy lin
wong honorary president of the black
environment network and amber rudd who
was secretary of state for energy and
climate change at paris in 2015. so
welcome to both of you so so much to
talk about judy today has been gender
day we're going to talk about that in a
moment but amber i'm interested to hear
from you your reaction to the news that
the prime minister boris johnson is
returning to glasgow tomorrow i mean
what hope that he could galvanize
progress is he in a position to make a
difference do you think well at least
he's acknowledged that this is probably
the most important thing that is going
on at the moment not only in the uk but
in the world so the fact that he's
prioritizing it is good news and let's
face it he always makes an impression so
i hope it'll be a positive impression
and people will feel additional
obligation to really arrive at a
compromise and an ambitious text at the
end of this week i think it's only good
news i mean in paris laurent fabius came
at the end as well sorry francois
hollande who is the prime minister who
is the president came at the end as well
because lauren fabius was the alex
sharma equivalent then and it does help
it shows that it's a real priority for
the host country so i hope it's going to
be helpful to getting that elusive
agreement is it a sign he's worried he
should be worried we're all worried
we're all worried whether we're actually
going to get a final text that is
ambitious and that actually delivers on
the hope that we all have so i think
being worried is the right place to be
at the moment
and i'm just going to bring in our data
dashboard if that's okay because this
summit is all about keeping the prospect
of 1.5 alive keeping global warming
capped at 1.5 i don't know if we can see
where we're at now but there's where
we're at at the moment just over 1.2
degrees at the moment so there's a tough
mission ahead and we've had analysis
from climate action tracker today
suggesting that we're not heading for
1.5 temperature rises will top 2.4
degrees celsius by the end of this
century based on the short-term goals
that the countries have set out it
doesn't look good does it no it is very
worrying i mean it just to remind
ourselves that in paris six years ago we
were at about four so there has been a
lot of progress but you know it is
terrifying to think that the climate
could rise over two degrees which is why
we should all be worried and ambitious
to try to get an agreement these are
really sobering worrying numbers which i
hope will help to galvanize the
politicians who are here doing the
negotiations over the text to real and
action because i know that everybody's
worried judy linguang let's talk about
what today's focus was here at cop
part of the session was devoted to
science and innovation but the other
part was agenda and i think you've been
involved in some of the discussions tell
us why you think it's so important that
we address this issue i mean we're told
aren't we that women are
disproportionately affected by climate
change
yes they are this is very worrying but
you know
all disadvantaged companies are sick and
tired of being told that the people need
to adapt and be resilient they want the
problem fixed let's not have to adapt
and be resilient the whole point is that
women make up half of the world's
population and we are a force that can
be switched on especially in the front
of green jobs you can switch on the
contribution by women so that it
actually accelerates social and economic
development in every single country and
the way you do this is really really
fundamental you need to put women in
positions of power not influence there's
a huge rising generation of activists
who are women but they're not power
wielders so what we're demanding as
women is that we want 50
presence on all decision making
structures from the lowest to the
highest so that we are part of the power
structure and what do you think about
this cop have
women's voices been heard enough do you
think
you know at the sessions where's all
women like the session i was in today
about gender sensitive transitions the
voices are strong and clear but we need
to be in all panels where the power is
and this is the real issue we want to be
there wielding power and not just
influencing with our voices our voices
are loud and clear and amber you
criticized the uk team didn't you you're
not having enough women on it
have they taken more with judy it's such
an important distinction there are lots
of women here who are campaigning who
are leading campaigning so the biggest
voices pointing out that women's voices
need to be heard and their lives taken
more seriously but in the
decision-making there are nowhere near
enough what i would like to see is that
the u.n to say that all delegations
should be 50 women i have criticized the
uk team we should have many more women
on the front of them because they are
the country who are hosting it so they
lead by example they're leading by
example on carbon reduction but not in
gender equality what was the reaction by
the way it wasn't wholly welcomed i have
to say but um doesn't stop us does it
judy no keep on shouting about it and
and do you think that the message has
got through that women are most
vulnerable to climate change and that
needs to be addressed that message is
really strong here and it has got you
but more interested in where there are
special opportunities to push and as i
said if women can get access to green
jobs we are forced and women can help
make decisions on the route to green
jobs so that it is really successful and
transforms the social and economic
development of single countries well you
were one woman on the uk delegation team
for cop 15 in paris which of course
ended up with that hugely successful
paris agreement so you know what it's
like to be at a cop and witness success
so does this have the same feeling about
it cop26 well the cop in paris also was
very worrying it was also very anxious
making you know we didn't know until the
last minute we were actually going to
get an agreement and in the end a more
ambitious agreement than we had hoped
for because it wasn't just limiting
increasing climate to two degrees but
keeping 1.5 in reach and now everybody
talks about 1.5 so you won't know till
the last minute and i have a message for
everybody here who is supporting other
people around these these discussions is
it won't necessarily end on time they do
often go on for a couple of days as i
ours did but i think this feels that it
is a worrying moment but i hope with the
prime minister arriving and other people
getting anxious about it it will
actually galvanize some action because
boy do we need an agreement and very
briefly judy how optimistic do you feel
i would be optimistic if the women start
getting into power wielding because we
come from a culture of caring which
means that we are about integrated
policy bringing together social cultural
environmental and economic outcomes and
if we get in there and put the detail in
we will make these programs succeed okay
judy linguang a strong message there and
to you amber ross thank you both thank
you appreciate it
don't forget you can listen to a new
climate cast every day and you can watch
our pop-up channel if you're not
watching it already climb it live on
channel 525. thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you